[Music]
less than 10 miles of the White House a
middle school is being terrorized by
ms-13 is called William Wirt middle
schools in Riverdale Maryland and it's
one of many whose makeup has been
changed entirely and almost overnight by
mass settlement of unaccompanied minors
entering this country from Latin America
now according to the Washington Post
ms-13 members in the school start fights
sell drugs rape fellow students teachers
say they fear being alone with a lot of
these kids they also fear saying
anything about it because speaking out
could cost them their jobs it's a
tragedy that can be traced almost
entirely to u.s. immigration policy but
elites don't seem to care at all and in
fact crush any conversation about it by
screaming racist needs to say their kids
will never attend William Wirt middle
school or anything even approaching it
Hosea rooster munot is a former DNC
press secretary and he joins us tonight
Jose thank you for coming on good to me
I found ironic about this story was this
is the kind of third in a iteration of
the ms-13 story first we were told they
don't really exist it's a figment of
your racist imagination then we were
told to attack them and call them names
as immoral because they're good people
okay now we have the Washington Post
telling us in detail about how they've
destroyed this middle school and are
terrorizing the students are we allowed
to acknowledge that or we bigots for
doing so well no let me start by saying
this if you're undocumented in this
country if you're a criminal including
being a member of ms-13 we don't want
you in this country and you should be
deported part of the issue here Tucker
is the people like yourself and some
Republicans want a pin point and just
simply say because your first name Jose
or you're Latino like me I'm
automatically an ms-13 gang member and
that is not true I'm a Georgia it's not
you're ridiculous person for saying that
I've never guessed anything like that
it's appalling that you would say that I
don't never suggested it I what you're
not you're speaking a lie and not for
the first time what I said is what I
read in the Washington Post which is
self-identified gang members are
destroying the school and terrorizing
people I bet you don't have kids at that
school but you never send your kids to
that school
you've got no problem with those people
being in this country because it fits
some sort of demographic you don't want
proof
no the truth is it's a disaster that's
is true let me I just said it if you're
an ms-13 gang member if you're
undocumented you should be deported a
majority of people who are not dogs
deported No
then why are you recently anybody no
yeah right nobody has said that the
majority of immigrants are criminals are
bad I'm not saying that I don't think it
what I am saying is they don't know that
he'd entities people come he has not
said that you're lying for political
gain as always what I have said and what
I think many normal people have said is
that we don't know who's coming into
this country we don't know anything
about them they're 20 million of them
living here we don't know their
identities their background some of them
are bad people okay so you know what we
do let me tell you what we do we pass
comprehensive immigration reform we
legalize a majority of people it will be
a whole lot easier talker to actually
look for the real criminals if we
legalize the good ones don't you think
so
Howard yeah I mean I it's hilarious that
that solution comports exactly with your
political goal which is to create more
democratic break that's not know you
tell me
totally rationally how if if illegal
immigration the inability of the US
government's know who's living within
its borders is the problem how
encouraging more of it which is what
amnesty would do is the solution there's
no logic you suggesting because didn't
solving okay so your answer and too many
Republicans answers to the poor the 14
million illegal immigrants undocumented
immigrants in this country so we're
guessing was guessing at that we're
guessing at that number some people
think it's 20 million okay I think
million a time what do we do when wage
growth has been stagnant and the cost of
everything is growing much faster than
the growth in wages you need to stop the
ability of employers to hire cheaper
people because they're here illegally we
need to make even joins it's really
important to not keep them hire people
legally no no look if you knew bothered
to learn anything about this subject if
you took it seriously we're bigger than
I tell you nothing about it then give me
a break if I'm telling you
about it I know more than your Wi-Fi and
holy room you know nothing you know no
more than why would an employer in this
country be allowed to hire someone
illegally depressing wages for American
citizens you want to fix up you want to
fix the problem we reform the system we
legalize the people that are already or
we legalize it no you could do it
tomorrow
why should employers be allowed to hire
illegal aliens I'm gonna say it again me
why they should be allowed Isis here a
talker we got two choices we deport the
14 million or 20 million whatever number
or we legalize shadow no we know what
time for conversations with people who
don't know what they're talking about
and haven't thought it through and want
to come on it's viewed more talking
points and call anybody who disagrees a
racist which is what you did in the very
first sentence of this segment because
that's what you yeah you're a peer
pathetic